I would love even though I do what I do
here I would love
to I would love to work a couple of days
a week at a
Geico I would love that I would
absolutely love for a couple of days a
week to just work at UH either a car car
insurance or something to just kind of
have a to have that feeling of like
getting in there you get your cup of
coffee sit down you open folders you
open a couple of files you get on the
computer here comes the emails we're all
rolling each other we're all rolling
eyes looking at each other like can you
[__] believe can you believe this can
you believe this [__] you know you go
out you smoke a cigarette with
somebody you talk about the company talk
about the business there's nothing
better than that there's nothing better
than being in a deadend job with other
losers I'm telling you all I'm around
right now as successful wealthy people
it's terrible it's miserable and
horrible horrible they all just want to
take iasa it's all these people want to
do is they're all so goddamn Rich all
they want to do is take um IA and open
their third eye and fourth eye and fifth
eye they want to all keep um just taking
uh different forms of DMT until the
aliens get so sick of them in hyperspace
they keep going you again these aliens
are in the other dimension going will
you go to work get a
job all these people are just every
every need you know every like
uh every need has been removed from
their lives so they're just like
endlessly trying to explore their inner
child they're like fingering their inner
child all the time it's like it's so
annoy like you can barely have a real
conversation with any of them because
they they they're they're up their own
ass so
far that they're
like it's crazy so there's nothing
better than being in a deadend job with
broke
losers who have given up because then
you're G actually have the best
conversations you some of the
deepest realest conversations I've ever
had with
anybody have certainly not at my friends
giving
but the the deepest realest ation I've
had with anybody have been outside of
like a call center or a mortgage office
or whatever smoking a cigarette in an
empty parking lot going what the [__]
are we gonna do how are how does
this you become like war
buddies in a shitty job where people
aren't going anywhere you actually have
it it becomes
fun now yes there's negatives to that
I'm not an
idiot but what I am saying is like you
close down all the offices you throw
away all the French vanilla creamer you
throw away all the
curig what do you think happens what do
you think happens to people when you
send them back to their domiciles and
tell them to work from home we would
have fundraisers and
stuff you know this is is uh now people
hate it people hate it it's
uh roundly criticized uh as being a
meaningless a meaningless way to spend
your life they what a meaning what a
meaningless way to spend your life in a
corporate Corporate America it's
meaningless you're so meaning to provide
for your wife and kids God it's
meaningless didn't you ever want to
paint and this idea that everybody is
just uh shoving all their
dreams uh down deep into them and then
going and there's some of that for sure
but also we're trying it's a s we're
running a society here someone's got to
work not everyone can [__] around all
the time not everyone's Gonna Be A
Millionaire because they invented a sock
company people are going to need to work
someone's got to be a cog in a machine
someone's got to be that guy someone's
got to be the guy that walks into the
office you go oh God it's him someone's
got to be that someone's got to
someone's got to be that the mail guy
George who's happy to give you the
mail where do these people go
everybody's not going this whole like
ethos of like online Hustler culture
that we think that like everybody is
just one crap psychology book away from
being the CEO of their own Empire is got
to stop it's got to go a convention is
nice going to a corporate convention
with other
losers is nice trying to get laid in a
corporate convention in in Cleveland
Ohio is a good
life you're not going to be a Kardashian
it does not haveen
happening it's not going to happen you
you you is things that are good the most
fun you're going to have is at a bar in
Cleveland Ohio at at at the
convention for pargal I don't know what
people do but the the point is this is a
good thing I I'm telling you that the
demise of commercial real estate is bad
I worry about
it nothing would make me happier than
for a day or two
to just be part of a of a corporate
culture again to go in and get a get an
email get an
email turn around to my buddy like hey
man he goes you you you were out
yesterday oof Deb was on a tear Deb was
on a tear dude Deb was on a [__] te
maybe trouble at home or something but
that [__] is
sick sick
like those convers it never happen
you're not allow it's like when you work
in those jobs you you're you're allowed
to hate it's encouraged you're allowed
to hate you're allowed to be bitter
resentful and and then you
know how are you GNA do that at home
that'll ruin your marriage your wife
doesn't care about your job she doesn't
want to hear about how much I hate
everybody that's why you have an office
you have friends you have Buddies you
get a cocktail after work you're all I
mean that's that's got to go somewhere
that that resentment that ball of anger
you have inside of you it's got to go
somewhere it's got to go to your buddies
to the left to the right what's wrong
with Deb she's a sick [__] Deb's a sick
[__] she's sick couple of weeks ago she
thought she was having a stroke that's
how [__] wound up she gets one day
she is gonna have a stroke because she's
sick man that has to go
somewhere you can't say that to your
wife at your
house remember
Deb Deb she's an
underwriter well she's sick no not not
no not physically she just some she's
something's wrong with her I hate her I
hate her will you talk to me about how
much I hate it'll never work it'll never
you'll be on a street your wife will
leave your wife will say something like
maybe she's going through something
something and you're like oh God oh God
well what's this I'm telling you people
go oh it's just a commercial real estate
crisis it is amputating a an essential
part of American society and
civilization that is not that'll only be
replaced by the way by uh uh further
entering the dark Hamas tunnel of the
internet which is not good we're at
we're at 55 already yeah God so much
else I want to talk
about but does anything I'm saying make
sense it
does this is a great uh defense here of
dead end jobs they're but they are
important
yeah they are really important and I
know that you don't agree with anything
I say because you you you know you drink
the Kool-Aid what do you mean meaning
that people your generation has been
everything I'm saying about the Embrace
of the deadend job the Embrace of the
sterile corporate culture uh is
antithetical to everything that you have
been told and everything that I have
been told too which is to follow your
dream and the rest of all that
horeshit right we're supposed to Aspire
yeah right but don't you but don't you
agree with me yeah I mean there's got to
be uh pawns too I mean we all heard that
phrase it's not even about pawns it's
the happiest you'll ever be in your life
to try telling you well anyone listen to
me the happiest you'll ever be in your
life is it a dead end j go you know Deb
I hope Deb gets shot in the
head I would love to see her shot in the
head everyone's laughing nothing's
better than a a a laugh at work a a
laugh at work your buddies go Chucks
hilarious he did this whole thing he
acted out Deb getting
raped but it's I'm just telling you I'm
telling you right
now uh I I I wish to God I wasn't rich
and I didn't live in this goddamn
Mansion I wish to God I worked at
Geico what do you mean stop there's
there's no way I'm Ser what do you mean
there's no way I mean you have you don't
understand anything about human nature
the complexities of it you want to go
back is what you're saying if I could
just work at a in a COR in a corporate
environment you
know I'm just saying for a day a day or
two and I would no you know but but you
I'm say I'm
saying it's fun I would love to get a
fun laugh and it's corporate it's a
corpor we're all in there this [__]
company not what it was we're all
sitting there we go it's not what it was
this company
huh used to work here used to be treated
differently they don't treat us they
don't treat us well anymore just to be
with a bunch of bitter losers bitter
resentful losers again getting mad at a
company they barely understand being
angry eating big sandwiches and being
angry with people hating [__] that
person [__] him how did he get that deal
his father is of course godamn it of
course you know it's
great I've ruined my goddamn
life I want to go back I want to work
for a
shady Financial comp not like really bad
but just kind of like you know just have
those moments again the corporate moment
your lunch is arrived your lunch has
arrived your lunch has arrived chicken
cutlet honey pesto Mayo roasted red
peppers on chabata a little side of
macaroni salad or tomato salad and
hatred hatred and
anger and pomposity to be pompous and to
know better and when the young guys come
in you go you don't really know how it
works I'll tell you how it works you
seem like a good kid like the
paramilitary structure of it all it's
beautiful it's [__] it's actually be
it's actually
beautiful compared to
Hamas compared to the other options you
know sex trafficking in Thailand or
whatever
yeah I'm telling you in certain
countries they put their own children in
sex
trafficking I think it's better to
work at
IBM I know it crushes your dreams I know
you want to be Fiona
Apple I know everybody wants to be Fiona
Apple out
there and everybody's that just wants to
go to Fiona Apple and be
deep
I know or Phoebe
[Music]
Bridges i' I'd respect Phoebe Bridges
more if she worked at
IBM
personally if she had all the talent she
did but still she worked at she would
never like she wouldn't quit she worked
at American Express
like like Phoebe Bridger and she sold
American Express cards at her concerts
like all these people you know wandered
in and they're all sad and she's got
great music but she's making them sadder
with that you know Sullivan or whatever
she sings that street song about the
street it is very good it's like a nice
sad Christmas song she's got a bunch of
them and and she's like after that and
then she goes and then she goes now you
all know also know that I work at
American Express and
everyone's and she goes I want to tell
you about a few of the benefits of this
card and then she like you know starts
doing interest rates and points and
everything and why do you have to why do
you have to choose one or the other why
do you have to choose one or the other
Kevin Hart's not he's B Chase he's got a
card out now he's got a card God I'd
love a card what about the Dylan card
Chase wouldn't do it who would do it hex
no we'd have to go we we got to go we we
got to go
low we got to find like a a teacher like
a Teacher's Credit Union for like you
know I mean we got to find like some
real scumbag
Arrangement I'm just telling you like I
this was a very the depth of this
episode is going to escape people
because people don't know how lucky they
are this is my point my point is this
and it's pretty it's a pretty Salient
Point people do not know how lucky they
are when there this this this mundane
life that you've
created is actually great this life of
nothing is actually good this life of
like oo someone brought Donuts is
actually good it's actually Peak
civilization how about that how about
that it's actually Peak civilization to
just get up roll out of bed head into
some office with a bunch of clowns eat a
dut and then just email somebody that
they've been denied for new liver or
whatever whatever the whatever the work
is doesn't even matter what the work is
you just email someone you go we're not
paying for that operation figure it out
and then you have a lunch with the guys
this this is Peak it's Peak and we're
past Peak not to be the bearer of bad
news but that's Peak Peak civilization
is like I'm bored at work I'm bored
don't you think the people in Gaza want
to be bored at work don't you think they
want to be the choosing which coffee
creamer to use you know it it it really
is sometimes I think I'm too smart for
the for to communicate with others and
that I should just sit kind of like The
Giver remember him that even speak no he
just took it all in and that's where I
think sometimes I am because I keep
trying to communicate with others and
I'm at a loss because who would defend
American Express who would defend Geico
who would say that that's the meaning of
life but it is all these people WR about
the meaning of life it really is to work
a I go that's the meaning of life like
the meaning of life not not you
know you know there's a lot of meanings
of life but one of the meanings of life
is to figure it
out to figure out how to just have food
and shelter you need you have basic
needs that need to get met and sometimes
you meet like no matter what you end up
doing there's going to be periods of
your life that you're going to work at
places you don't like you know this is
what's going to hen you're not EV
everybody's not going to be uh I don't
know the people on Stranger Things those
kids like and they they're gonna pay
late they're gonna pay later they get to
pay later and everyone pays everyone pay
you don't get out without paying you
know
so what I'm saying and and a lot of
people might disagree with me is that a
a dead end corporate
gig where you're not too low and you're
not too high and you're just kind of
riding in the
middle and you're going uh you got a
couple of free tickets to the game
you're taking some client he's a real
schmuck but you know he might reup with
you you realize that's it that is every
you did it you did it cuz the war The
World Is War and hell and famine and
chaos and you know or or people taking
iasa in their Rolls-Royce try to figure
out how deep is it how do I I need to
actualize but that's what it comes down
to so when you look at the state of
chaos it's all over the world the idea
that you have some boring deadend
corporate job is actually quite an
accomplishment not only of you but of
the people around you yes or yes be
happy with those things fight for
them fight for the office we're going
back we're going back we're go where's
that energy it's all for Israel and the
Palestine where is the energy to go back
into the office to crawl back into it
crawl into it we're going back we're
going
back
protest get your fat ass back in theice
office cuz Deb is a sick [__] and you
want to tell someone about it you I'm
telling you life will not get better
fight for this no one's going to listen
to
me God they'll play this years from now
years from now after the people in this
town have had me killed years from now
someone will hear this and they go God
he was [__] right God he was right we
should have fought for the shitty Little
Deli in the basement of the building we
should have fought fought for our office
we should have fought for the breakroom
we should have fought for it for
civilization we should have fought when
we had the chance we didn't because we
were all
pompus and we all thought we were better
than that and we didn't need it we
didn't need to see each other in the
flesh or talk to each other that life
was a series of gigs or
[Music]
schemes jobs were for
losers schemes were better gigs were
better even though they only enriched
the [__] apps on our phones and kept
us on a Perpetual wheel offered us
nothing in the way of cohesive social
environments we all became lonely freaks
in our cars our houses our apartments on
messenger bikes task rabbit showing up
inst stalling a TV and then
leaving all of this stuff we didn't
fight for the Great American office the
great dead end job the great middle
class mediocre God I wish I had [__]
applied myself in college and I wouldn't
be in this dump the great backyard beer
with your neighbor [__] this place 30
years they tell you to [__] off at the
end I'm telling you you didn't fight for
it when you had the chance
the biggest regret of my life is that I
don't work in an insurance
company in
Ohio the
privilege the
privilege you think I like driving this
Bentley it ruins every other
car I'm in a rental right now it's it's
insane it's an Infinity it's insane
I don't even know how it even happens
this Infinity truck is
horrible my greatest regret in my life
is that I do not work in Insurance in
Ohio be
smart fight for these things I'm telling
you so many of you are not smart enough
to understand this episode it's very
hard it's very hard for me how do I have
a career at
all
right you're right because now I was
killed in a
tunnel by
mr6 and the mord all right all right you
keep doing this all the time but you're
right I actually believe that the
happiest I've ever been is not when I
was going to Africa pretending to care
about the babies the happiest I've ever
been was when I was in a bank with my
girlfriends and we was all talking about
who had bigger dicks the or the bankers
which Banker had the biggest dick that
was really fun I didn't like Africa it
was
depressing that's Princess Diana saying
what we all
know well I I hope do do you understand
what I'm saying you you've shook your
head multiple times but is it it's be
it's so hard I think to fully grasp if
you're not a a full
genius I'm not as as enlightened as you
but I I do see where you're coming from
I do see you know how the the mundanity
can be enjoyable it is it is not only is
it enjoyable it is it that is it that is
it that is it that is it enjoy that
there's a few Great Moments and a few
terrible ones but in that in what you do
every day is what your life is people
don't realize that and they don't
realize the purpose is serves they're
always looking for something else it's
very American to do that by the way